big thank you today to Timothy Egan
Berger Timothy is today's new david
pakman show member of the day joining
more than 300 more than 300 new members
in January alone for the David Pakman
show
Irie I'm flattered I'm flabbergasted I
am something else with an F that's even
bigger and better than that at the
support that we are getting from folks
early in this 2019 Timothy just one of
the new members of the month and also
Steven Kaplan is today's sustaining
member of the day he's been with us
nearly 5 years thanks to even very much
appreciate your support become a member
if you value what we do if you're new
here you don't know if you value what we
do no big deal don't support us if you
don't have the money to support
independent media shows no problem I'm
still doing the show for you the show is
for everybody but if you have the means
and you value the work that we do and
you understand the importance of
supporting media outlets that reflect
our values become a member it's really
cheap you can do it at WWE and
pakman.com it's the right thing to do
you'll feel good about it I'll feel good
about it
Pat will feel better about it than you
can even imagine and it'll be a good
thing for everybody so thanks to
everybody who has already supported us
and who is planning to very very soon
okay it's time for hatred mail if you've
forgotten about hatred mail quick
reminder about hatred mail hey we'd
probably poison our entire family if
Trump told us to but remember it's not a
cult
patriot mail written by Patriots who
hate David Pakman because America and
because freedom ok this week's hatred
mail is going to need a little
interpretation if you are only listening
the read-along transcript that we are
putting up on the screen is important in
this particular week's episode let's
take a listen together
hey David punk man you can bash Trump
all you want he won you're the loser
those men who don't feel manly and I'll
include women are the perverts of the
world David you're the biggest douche on
YouTube you brain-dead leftist David
Pakman macron that macaroni is a loser
like you
I bet David brushes his teeth daily ha
ha loser you know uh guilty as charged
I admit I do brush my teeth not just
once but twice daily morning and night
and if something were to happen during
the day that warrants a third brushing
i'm not going to shy away from that that
i do admit but beyond that i am a little
confused by the idea that women who
don't feel manly are perverted because I
thought that this contingent thought
that it is the transgender individuals
who feel as though they actually are of
a different gender are the ones who are
the perverts according to them but now
this hatred is saying that women who
don't feel manly are perverted I thought
that's what the anti trans crowd wanted
pat that women should not feel manly
they're contradicting themselves and
another point here you're upset because
Trump won and you just can't accept that
and that makes you a loser
well Emmanuel macron who the hatred also
mentions is called by a loser by the
hatred and yet he won his election too
so I'm just totally confused on this one
I think you're pointing out that hatreds
may not be completely consistent and may
have some deeply held double standards I
think that that is not going to come as
a shock to many people remember you can
use the coupon code hey tree at 40 to
become a member with a 40% discount when
you use the coupon code hey tree at 40
at join pakman.com for a membership you
get a 40% discount and many many many
hatreds cry they're so upset that their
hatred system has not prevented the
david pakman show from continuing to
garner support so that's available
coupon code hey tree at 40